today we will be explaining the entire
attack on titan's story in only 10
minutes well no time to waste let's get
started
[Applause]
ymir a young slave of the aldean tribe
gains the power of the titans from an
unknown anomaly becoming the first
founding titan the king of the eldian
tribe flees with yamir's power and
accomplishments takes her to bear his
children ymir fritz defends her king
from an assassination attempt at the
hands of a marlin soldier choosing to
succumb to death from her wound the king
of eldea feeds yamir's corpse to his
daughters maria rose and gina who
inherit ymir's power over the titans
ymir fitz's consciousness survives in
the paths a metaphysical timeless space
where she creates the bodies of the
titans and carries out the commands of
the living royal family through the
founding titan ymir's daughters bestow
their power of the titans under their
grandchildren leading to the eventual
creation of the nine titan powers two
thousand years later marley sends out
vertolt reiner annie and marcel from the
levarion tournament zone to commence the
paradise island operation before leaving
for the interior grisha promises his son
aaron that he will one day show him the
secrets kept within the basement of
their home after arriving at walmaria
bertolt hoover as the colossus titan
breaches the outer gate of shigan china
district allowing countless titans to
enter the city dina fritz's pure titan
enters the city finding and eating
grisha's wife carla in front of aaron
and mikasa grisha yeager travels to the
reese chapel and urges frederic to stop
the titan invasion he battles frida's
titan and defeats her taking the
founding titan he then takes aaron into
a forest and passes the founding titan
onto him the colossus titan breaches the
outer gate of tross district resulting
in a titan invasion for the first time
in five years aaron jaeger is eaten by a
titan but emerges in his first attack
titan form and begins to slaughter
titans in the city aaron uses his titan
powers consciously for the first time
biting his hand to create a huge titan
skeleton to protect mikasa and armin and
himself from a cannonball aaron is held
on trial before a military tribunal
judged by commander in chief darius
zackly he is eventually given over to
the custody of the survey corps the
survey corps embarks on the 57th
expedition outside the walls annie
disrupts the expedition as the female
titan commander irwin leads her into a
titan forest and successfully uses
special target restraining weapons to
capture her but she manages to escape
aaron battles annie in the titan forest
but is defeated and kidnapped by annie
before she can escape mikasa and levi
arrive to rescue aaron in stow house
district the survey corps attempt to
quietly capture annie leonhart but she
transforms into a titan after failing to
escape the district annie encases
herself in a crystalline substance to
avoid capture zeke yeager invades while
rose as the beast titan using his
abilities to turn the residents of
rigako into titans under his control
ymir transforms into a titan to protect
the remaining recruits at utgard castle
reiner braun and bertold hoover reveal
their titan identities to aaron and
transform a battle ensues on wall rose
aaron and ymir are captured by reiner
and bertolt they attempt to flee to
walmaria but are intercepted by the
survey corps who managed to rescue aaron
from their grasp the smiling titan
appears in front of aaron and mikasa
aaron unleashes the power of the
founding titan unknowingly after
striking the smiling titan's hand reiner
and bertolt retreat to shigenchina
district with the amir in trost irwin
smith and dot pixas begin to fight
against the royal government levi
forcefully convinces astoria to agree to
her role as queen squad levi receives
irwin's plan for overthrowing the
monarchy kenny ackerman's squad ambushes
squad levi and the battle breaks out
over the streets of stohas erwin smith
is brought before king fritz and the
assembly as they order him to the
gallows darry exactly intervenes
arresting the nobles and dethroning
fritz aaron awakens in a cave below the
reece chapel by placing their hands on
his back rod and historia trigger
aaron's memories of grisha's final hours
squad levi arrives at the reese chapel
in battles with kenny's anti-personal
control squad rod reese drinks from the
titan serum shattered by historia
becoming an enormous pure titan with the
combined efforts of the garrison aaron
and squad levi rodrice's titan is
defeated at orvik district with historia
landing the killing blow kenny ackerman
is found by levi outside of the
collapsed cavern he reveals that he is
levi's uncle and gives levi a titan
serum he stole from rod before dying his
story eris is ceremonially crowned queen
of the walls zeke arrives in chicago
district meeting reiner and bertolt
squad levi visits keith shadus to learn
of his involvement with grisha jaeger he
thousand of his past with grisha erwin
smith leads over 100 soldiers of the
survey corps on an expedition to shigan
china aaron uses his hardening ability
to seal the breach in the outer gate
zeke as the beast titan traps the survey
court in shigan china with a titan army
aaron and reiner battle in their titan
forms vertolt transforms into the
colossus titan above shiegan china the
beast titan bombards the survey corps
irwin smith leads a last-ditch frontal
charge into the line of fire as a
distraction for levi levi successfully
defeats the beast's titan cutting zeke
out of its nape zeke is rescued by peak
and the two flee toward qigon china
armin arlett sacrifices himself in a
divisionary attack against the colossus
titan whom aaron defeats after leaving
his titan form cutting bertolt out of
its nape both armin and irwin are found
to be alive but on the brink of death
ultimately it is decided by levi that
armin will be given the serum armin
eatsper told hoover and irwin smith dies
aaron mikasa levi and hanji investigate
the basement of the jaeger household
where they discover three books left by
grisha the nine survivors of the battle
of shigun china district are honored in
ceremony by queen historia zeke yeager
meets with kyomiya zumabito in private
revealing his true allegiance to eldea
survey corps sets out beyond while maria
reaching the borderline wall in the
shores of the ocean marley sends out
their first survey fleet to paradise
island they are intercepted by the
survey corps the anti-marlene volunteers
on board defect to the people of the
wall side marley's war with the mid-east
allied forces culminates at fort slava
the results of this battle brings an end
to the marley mid-east war aaron yeager
infiltrates marley using aaron kruger's
identity the tiber family comes to
liberia to make preparations for an
upcoming festival of world ambassadors
on the night of the festival falco
brings reinerbraun to meet with aaron
who is hiding in a basement behind the
festival stage when willy timer declares
war on paradise island aaron transforms
into the attack titan and kills him
before going on a rampage the younger
sister of willy transforms into the
warhammer titan and attacks aaron the
survey corps enter the battle and engage
the marlene soldiers the jaw kart and
beast titans join the expanding battle
shortly after armand arler uses his
colossus titan to destroy the docking
fleet levi neutralizes the beast titan
and aaron uses the john titan's powerful
jaws to crack open the younger sister of
willy's crystal inheriting the warhammer
titan gabby and falco also board the
airship where gabby shoots and kills
sasha aaron yeager is arrested and
placed in an underground cell on account
of his insubordination zeke yeager is
placed under house arrest in a forest of
giant trees and kept under close
scrutiny by levi a group of survey corps
recruits plan a bomb to assassinate
zackly that same day aaron yeager uses
his titan powers to escape his cell peak
successfully infiltrates the walls once
more zeke is defeated by levi after
transforming the cervical guarding him
into titans as levi rides back to the
walls zeke detonates a thunderspear he
is saved by pure titan who stuffs him
inside his stomach allowing yamir fritz
to rebuild his body in the path's
dimension peak and gabby are taken to
the roof to point out the location of
said marlene infiltrators when porco in
his jaw titan form attacks aaron as a
part of the marlene surprise attack
aaron narrowly avoiding getting eaten
before transforming marley initiates its
attack on paradise island reinerbraun
and porco galliard engage aaron jaeger
in combat onion coupon releases the
imprisoned soldiers in the hopes that
they will help protect aaron from being
killed by the invading forces zeke
yeager arrives atop the wall of shigun
china district assisting the altean
counterattack by throwing rocks and
marlene airships downing all of them the
beast titan is brought down by theo
mageth operating anti-titan artillery
mounted on the cart titan's back colt
tries to reason with zeke not to scream
as falco ingested his spinal fluid the
zeke ultimately decides to go through
with his plan falco along with everyone
who drank the wine is transformed into a
pure titan aaron escapes his titan form
and rushes towards zeke gabby shoots
aaron through the neck blowing his head
cleanly off the rest of his body zeke
catches aaron's head before the ladder's
brain activity ceases transporting both
of them to the path's realm inside the
paths they go through grisha's memories
all the walls on the island start to
crumble as the wall titans emerge and
the rumbling is set into motion aaron
telepathically speaks to all eldins
across the world and explains that he
will destroy the entire world for lda's
safety at the same time all hardening
has come undone and andy leonhardt is
set free from her crystal reiner is put
out of commission after getting his
armor stripped and gaby braun goes out
to save falco grice peak and mageth
watch the airship's retreat as hanji and
levi approach to meet them they agree to
team up to stop the rumbling armin
connie gabby and falco reach frost and
find annie who decides to go with him to
stop the rumbling in shigun china peak
rescues onion gophen elena and jean
others ride out to find and recruit
reiner they find him and convince him to
join up in the new alliance and stop
aaron the group heads out towards the
port pete comes back from scouting and
relays that the jaegers have the port
captured along with kiyomi and her
engineers the global alliance's fleet is
destroyed by the rumbling as it finally
reaches marley and begins to trample
everything they begin to plan their
attack of rescuing the azumabitos and
stealing the flying boat after rescuing
azumabitos they arrive in hodiha the
group bids farewell to annie who has
decided to stay behind before the group
can depart flock reveals himself and
shoots holes in the boat's fuel tank
mikasa fires one of her anchors into
flock's throat killing him they depart
just in time to escape aaron's titan as
hanji stays behind to slow them down and
dies as aaron approaches fort salta he
summons mikasa armin gene connie levi
reiner and pique into the paths to speak
with them his former comrades beg him to
stop the rumbling as the flying boat
reaches aaron the boat becomes under
fire from the beast titan as the group
attempt to reach aaron's nape to destroy
it aaron summons all the past titan
shifters to protect him despite this the
soldiers eventually managed to reach
aaron's nape and blow it up aaron's head
transforms again into a new colossus
farm he is met by armin who chooses to
engage him in a hand-to-hand fight aaron
manages to defeat him but armin manages
to immobilize him long enough for mikasa
to enter his titan mouth and kill him by
severing his head from the spine before
kissing him goodbye in the three years
following the battle of heaven and earth
at fort salta armin and the other
survivors are appointed as diplomats to
facilitate peace talks between the
outside world and paradise island mikasa
and armin decide to bury aaron's head at
the foot of the tree he like to nap
under outside of shiganshina district
and there you go guys that's the whole
story of attack on titan explained in
only 10 minutes click on this video to
learn about the entire story of aaron
yeager i know you're still here go on
click it